l'humilité le courage l'amour le dont la
transmission ou encore l'erreur humaine
des valeurs des idées des concepts mais
surtout des choses importantes pour
gilles vuille à ce plasticien depuis 30
ans l'artiste présente à la galerie le
corbusier ont ce thème à caractère
universel une envie déclenchée suite à
son exposition mythe en abyme présenté
en 2013 à la commanderie des templiers
d'elancourt gilles travaillait sur
les mythologies contemporaines et les
mythologies antiques et je crois que
dans les mythes dans ces systèmes dans
ces structures symbolique il y a des
choses qu'on retrouve de manière
universelle partout et les thèmes qu'il
développe ici sont issus je pense tout
ce qu'il a pu apprendre dans limite pour
rendre compte de ces concepts gilles
guillet se personnalise l'universel pour
l'illustrer l'artiste travaille sur
trois formats différents
il dessine d'abord sur petit format ou
crayons de couleur et pastels pour
pouvoir image et sa pensée n'importe où
et après une fois qu'il rentre à
l'atelier il fait des travaux un peu
plus grand en format raisin 50 70 à
l'acrylique où il commence à mettre en
scène de manière un peu plus structuré
les petits dessins et après il fait des
grandes peintures qui fait d'abord un
dessin au fusain et ensuite il met des
couches d'acrylique eux qu'il superpose
dessus et un moment donné quand la
peinture lui paraît incarner qu'elle est
présente puisqu'il s'agit personnages
donc comme si ses personnages étaient en
face de lui
eh bien ils les arrête l'artiste dévoile
une position personnelle sur un sujet
humain et propose un questionnement à
celui qui regarde
pour gilles vuille as une oeuvre
plastique au delà de déclencher une
émotion doit provoquer la réflexion